PRACTICE THAT THEY NEVER HAD
EARLIER.
>> INTERESTING.
>> DR. JEMISON, I KNOW FOLKS
WATCHING MAY BE ASKING THE
QUESTION, WE WENT TO THE MOON
DECADES AGO, WHY WOULD WE BE
GOING AGAIN?
BUT THE BIG PICTURE OF THE
ARTEMIS PROGRAM IS NOT JUST TO
GET TO THE MOON, BY THE WAY,
VERY SIGNIFICANT IT WILL BE THE
FIRST WOMAN, THE FIRST PERSON OF
COLOR TO STEP FOOT ON THE MOON,
BUT ALSO THIS IS ABOUT
EVENTUALLY THIS IS ABOUT MARS,
RIGHT, AND GETTING TO MARS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW THE TWO ARE
TIED TOGETHER AND HOW THE MOON
HELPS WITH MARS?
>> WELL, I WANT TO SEPARATE IT A
LITTLE BIT FIRST.
>> SURE.
>> GOING BACK TO THE MOON IN AND
OF ITSELF AND ESTABLISHING A
PERMANENT PRESENCE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN AND OF
ITSELF.
AND THAT MEANS THAT YOU'RE ABLE
TO DO OBSERVATIONS, ASTRONOMICAL
OBSERVATIONS, SEE THE EARTH.
YOU CAN ALSO DO THINGS THAT HAVE
TO DO WITH MANUFACTURING.
SO, THERE'S A LOT TO DO JUST BY
BEING ON THE MOON ITSELF IN A
PERMANENT WAY.
NOW, IT ALSO GIVES YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRACTICE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT NEEDED FOR LONG
DURATION DEEP SPACEFLIGHTS LIKE
GOING TO MARS.
AND THAT IS, UNDERSTANDING THE
RADIATION, UNDERSTANDING WHAT
HAPPENS TO HUMANS IN THESE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF GRAVITATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTS.
IT ALSO GIVES YOU, THE WAY THIS
IS SET UP, A GATEWAY STATION FOR
EVEN CONSTRUCTING THE VEHICLE
OUTSIDE OF THE EARTH'S ORBIT.
THIS IS A REALLY INTERESTING
MECHANISM TO GO TO MARS.
AND PEOPLE MIGHT ASK, WHY DO YOU
WANT TO GO TO MARS?
WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S OUR CLOSEST
NEIGHBORING PLANET, BUT THE
OTHER PART OF IT IS, WE HAVE SO
MUCH TO LEARN ABOUT THE GEOLOGY
OF MARS.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO LEARN ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS TO PLANETS AND
THEIR ATMOSPHERES.
DOING THAT IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS WELL.
SO, THE MOON IS A BASE THAT'S
IMPORTANT IN AND OF ITSELF, BUT
IT HELPS FACILITATE GOING TO
MARS.
>> JONATHAN, READING ABOUT THE
EXPERIMENTS PLANNED FOR THE
MOON, TECHNOLOGY HAS OBVIOUSLY
ADVANCED ENORMOUSLY IN THE LAST
50 YEARS.
I'VE BEEN READING ABOUT THINGS
LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO
CRYOGENICALLY FREEZE SOME
SAMPLES ON THE MOON'S SURFACE TO
BRING THEM BACK.
THEY'RE GOING TO TEST IN AREAS
THAT ARE NOT -- THAT DON'T
ENCOUNTER THE SUN.
YOU KNOW, THINGS THEY WEREN'T
ABLE TO DO IN THE LATE '60s AND
EARLY '70s.
DOES THAT HAVE SCIENTIFIC OR HOW
MUCH, I SHOULD SAY, SCIENTIFIC
IMPORTANCE DOES THAT HAVE?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT'S VERY
INTERESTING.
AND REALLY IT ALL TIES INTO
LEARNING TO LIVE OFF THE EARTH.
SO, I THINK THE REAL IMPLICATION
IS, AS DR. JEMISON SAID, WE WANT
TO GO TO A FUTURE WHERE THERE
ARE HUMANS THROUGHOUT THE SOLAR
SYSTEM.
THE MOON IS LIKE, IF ANYTHING
GOES WRONG ON THE MOON, YOU'RE
ONLY A FEW DAYS FROM HOME.
SO IT'S A LOT BETTER TO PRACTICE
THERE THAN TO GO TO MARS RIGHT
AWAY.
AND THE EARLY -- THE APOLLO
MISSIONS COULD ONLY LAND IN A
VERY FEW AREAS OF THE MOON.
NEAR THE MOON'S EQUATOR.
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
AND LAND NEAR THE LUNAR SOUTH
POLE, WHICH IS A VERY EXCITING
AREA SCIENTIFICA